hey guys welcome back to another video
you're about to watch the finale of the
agent matter cake defy christmas arena
this is a tournament that crashed leech
us on december 21st it attracted so many
of the top players in the world
including magnus hikaru
and karjakin who i unknowingly played
and maybe beat stay tuned for that one
as usual i'm gonna time stamp every
single game in the video description so
feel free to hop around or just watch
the whole thing through that's always
appreciated and do let me know your
favorite game in the comments
and without further ado let's get to
some chess
i think what i'm gonna do is mute alerts
during the tournament just so i can try
and find full focus ten
nine and here we go
seven
six
five oh where am i i'm gonna be playing
one of these two
one thank you ross
[Music]
time
yeah this is a dubious opening but i've
had this position before
so i'm down the pawn but i have two
bishops
that's something to work with
interesting move
work
[Music]
[Music]
yeah final position was losing what to
do
not even any cell matrix ah okay
first game
that's the life
try and move on
no berserking this game
ah this line
[Music]
take
there's some weird knight seat for it at
some point
look at how it works though
so i hit the knight
i want to play a5
slightly difficult position
it's weird to adjust from two minutes to
one minute
i'm losing a piece unfortunately
it's still weird though
i think it's just losing but we'll see
if my opponent can
figure things out
some hope though
[Music]
am i winning i might be winning
winning
let's go okay somehow i won that
uh persistence pays off let's go
83rd place
ricardo have a draw looks like a draw
[Music]
i want a berserk but i don't know if
players will deserve back
so i'm pinning i was pinning the pawn
and chase away this bishop
getting h2
okay so somewhat symmetrical position
the goal is to stay up on time
that's slightly annoying might be seven
maybe
i'm still alive here
i just want to trade all the rooks
wow
um
[Music]
i have some weird move
try it
so hitting the knight this pawn is
hanging
it's probably losing for me but
worth a try
is white's knight getting trapped
there should be six coming
there's b1 i play b4 king f2 bishop b6
takes takes i think it's winning
actually
some freak accident for white this
knight's trapped
and we can't take because then i promote
the pawn
i'm basically winning on time and in the
position
let's go okay
thanks everyone for subbing
uh alerts are muted
i played vodnik the other day
yeah no berserking
vladimir actually beat me the other day
very similar line
i have this line
hmm
me
let's go okay let's go i took work
i know my heart rate was high there i
was nervous let's go
oh this line again
oh what's this line
if i just draw
i i don't remember the theory
i'll just draw and play another game
but i don't remember the theory
okay
join
let the heart rate settle down a little
bit i'm top 50
over 2700
playing we tick
okay so now this is two minute chests
oh this line
if knight d4 i'll play the exchange
stack variation
c5 the move i think c5 is a move
c8
51 is a little bit annoying
so 96 queen c8 i think was okay for me
who wants to be here
[Music]
hmm
so b3 a6
we trade i have rook c3 in the end
rook c2 coming
basics just blended upon
i have this move
knight d4
it's still interesting though
i'll play knight b3
so i triple fork everything
that's a move
there's a really interesting line
the a6 takes knight e3 kh3 work f2 a7 i
don't think i'm mating there
unfortunately
[Music]
let's go queenie two mates
let's go
i had to find my zone there
oh man
i was worse at some point probably i'm
playing rob the guy in fifth place
lost to rob three times before
i've been robbed once
mowing upon takes queen takes
might be winning a pawn here
and a
piece
oh i didn't see that move
still okay though
you have a pawn
um takes
there's 92
and b593 takes
e3 c6 is weak there
want to play d5
um
should still be okay
but i don't
know i mess this up
i want to take and play knight e5 and f4
d7
g4 here
let's move
[Music]
no
still alive
[Music]
oh i was winning too oh i tricked him
i tricked him with the premium thing
oh
[Music]
okay
so calm down calm
it's
down
time almost free moved d6 i would have
been tragic
ultra staffer gambit
um yeah bishop c4 is not a great move
but
uh yeah we'll go into this
so queen f3 i'll play 95
and probably queen e2 queen h4
if i take
i think it makes sense to take
so i'm looking at um a pawn sprint
considering this but i have bishop d4
and again if takes bishop d4 and i'll
take on c4
oh i miss that oh i have this move
hey thank you you see a boat
appreciate the gifted subs
i have to defend
e5 might be coming
this move
not pretty but
it's something
i do queen b6
i don't mind trading
94 yeah king hhh point was running the
pork
letting b2
india b6
so c7 is hanging
[Music]
i can take and play b6 anyway
and see
queen c4
three now
we got five over five is tricky though
i just blundering
i'm still playable
a lot of pawns for the piece
it might be getting mated though
oh no
do you want
it's holding on for dear life here
[Music]
play this move
i just wondered
still
alive
you'll have some light
oh it's losing
yeah ah what to do ah
good position too
just blended a piece
you kenny the prime sub
okay 88th place
uh that was kind of a tilt berserk but
trying to make two here
so if takes i
i don't actually know if rock h5 works
but
looks interesting
[Music]
the united four
being the knights
i do g5
very very short position
for 25 i have knight b3
now i hit this
okay this is winning now
he takes f5 there's a funny pre-move too
i saw it coming because if i pre-move
right h7 it could be
a slight concern
okay berserk win let's go
got the london style attack
so 74th place
i was just plundering
oh to do
i should resign i'll resign
not my proudest game ever but that's
part of life
just gonna move on
oh playing cruel yarrow played him
earlier before the tournament
i'll play with stafford
if he wants one
ah this line h5
he's handling it well so far
i'm not getting
i usually hope for in the stafford
i'll do this stuff
bc5 at the right moment
look here
good move
my king should be in the center
what is this position
don't hurt me
funny line coming
oh it's not funny though
oh there's rook there
i thought it was funny
never resign when you have a rook
oh i meant to okay there was my rook
oh
i'm playing fritzy
another staffer gambit
another refutation too
ah bishop for oh i was looking at bishop
for the other day what should i conclude
i already forgot
oh white has menacing pawns again
she has a thematic break in this type of
position
okay at least getting some counter play
i miss that move
[Music]
oh no i got mated ah
that was a strong player
okay top hundred would be a decent
finish
hey i'm playing levy i'm levy what's up
lovie
long time no see
i'm dear friend
is lovey streaming
imagine love you streaming
oh levy with his annoying attacks
this is maybe playable
oh i just lost an
exchange he's playing well
levy knows i don't resign though
[Music]
oh i blended her rook
there's still some hope of stalemate
right
oh my queen
oh
good game lovey
hey it's la fong am i gonna play la fong
next
i've reached the point where i play all
the streamers
maybe
[Music]
playing bmw
okay 43 minutes left
around the halfway point
i just want to take and
ah this line
bishop here
she looks reasonable either for coming
never mind
f3
still want to play another four
you take first
interesting
yeah queen b6 is going to hurt me
let's take screen b6
black ones back upon
um
i'll play this move
i'll lose one of my d pawns
the g5 coming
i don't think g5 is good though
g4
[Music]
looks interesting
do i have g5
looks risky
let's do it
trying to win this pawn
just want to put the bishop on a safe
square
trade queens
[Music]
in this pawn
yeah coin can't quite play rook t1
[Music]
who's gonna dirty flag who
it should be peacefully agreed to a draw
drop
why have we not repeated
yet oh wow
okay that's a draw
i mean i can't really play for a win
there
the appointment had too much time
playing cappuccino
i just fall into some like weird opening
trap
maybe it's okay
oh
very fancy
oh no
[Music]
i just fell into some
some really bad opening trap
oh
okay i resign
i lost in 12 moves what was that opening
some weird like danish
i declined the danish but i just got
absolutely smashed there
i should try that opening someday
it's berserk ah i wanted to berserk
okay normal london play knight e5
hmm
freaking g4
yeah it's a pleasant position
[Music]
and i have three on the horizon
queensland castling
some bishops c4 eventually
to be a little bit careful
[Music]
is king b2 coming
yeah there's some danger of queen a4
this isn't so simple actually
i have a4
box probably in the sack
there's also bishop e3 which
i have this move
this looks really dangerous though
yeah bishop b3 i think i play this
this move
i was going for counter play
yeah that's a move
no king there doesn't work
does anything work here
oh this is really bad
[Music]
oh no
i still have rook g6 some hope
maybe
probably not though
take your time
take your sweet time
everyone's really taking their time here
and now i'm alive because
yeah i mean black could have cashed in
[Music]
okay now let's go full defense mode
no i took with the wrong thing i had to
take with queen
ah
my reflexes just took over there
that's the only move ah
i had the dirty flag
ready
[Music]
okay now i'll filter zurich
that was very tilting
okay opponent wants to meet me
this is how you refute scholars mate
it's a playable opening though
let's move back
back to d8 and just develop
yeah i'm trying to open some files on
the queen side
now simple idea queen
queen here there's also a cool idea
night here
i'll start with this
i'll play d5
gotta move a bit quicker here
of takes i check and mate
doing my best to attack
[Music]
you
let's go let's go
almost got dirty flag there
oh that's close
wow
[Music]
the car was still leading
oops that's not a good opening
what's this opening
why is my bishop on e3
that's why
okay that's essentially what i want
i'm trying to work up the minority
attack
let's hop upon
up a rook
let's go okay
i had to just hypnotize my opponent with
the rook moves there
okay still top 150
alabama win there
berserk again
okay accidental kings indian
i don't really play the king's indian
bro
but i'll try and uh
try and improvise
winning 1 or
28 some b5 idea
reminiscent of last game actually
positional rook ending
this pawn is regretting its life
decisions
okay let's go
trying to break back into the top
hundred
the car was still leading but it's kind
of close
playing bmw hero again
i'm grabbing the full center
wow
i fancy move
i can take and play bishop g5
that's murky though queen b2
maybe it works out
two things hanging
don't think black has any counter
attacks
okay there is that move though
oh i lost a pawn in the process what
i'm down the pawn
try and harass the bishop
i think each for
trying to create some chaos on the king
side
and now bishop h5 preventing your k8
that's a good move
go after c7
i'm in some trouble
and your rook e1 to h1
that phone's playing precisely
not much hope here
i'll resign pretty soon
any hope
okay there goes my king what to do
playing algorithm
running
this let's make it sharp
it's not a good decision
this is really unpleasant
don't even know what to do here
play a chief
ss move
that's a free bishop
i control the only open file
[Music]
you
oh
what to do
what to do i was almost surviving
opponent did blunder their their thing
at some point
well the pawns were too menacing
[Music]
okay
try and finish strong
and overcome the tilt
i love g5 there
hmm
go
the lag of focus
oh
thank you into a queen for the raid
oh good timing
okay
try and recover
okay this is a really nice opening
got my knight on d6 this knight is
pinned
f6 probably there's about f4
around this pawns attacked
this
work sense to take first
okay
looks like i'll win a game
hopefully
oops
oops no
i just blundered away two pieces in one
move
or two moves
i got way too relaxed there
i'm still gonna win probably
i don't think i deserve it but that's
sometimes how life goes
okay now i'm up a piece again
what a game
oh it's too funny
okay
oh
what was that game
[Music]
let's try and get 100 tournament points
[Music]
yeah that game felt like kangaroo chess
i messed up d4
i don't even play this opening
in queen e1 and e4 i guess
does it move
this is a move tactics
because it takes this is a
zwischenzug i guess there is a queen d2
man there but
okay
pop a pawn
after a mouse slip opening
when plunder's this
that may have been a sacrifice though
okay that's not coming
it's a little bit uncomfortable
queen f3
i should probably sock back
yeah especially because now my bishop's
happier
now there's a pin
[Music]
g4 is probably respectable
now just going for the kill
[Music]
yeah there's not really a great way to
defend rookie 7 i win the queen at least
queenie here i check and with the queen
okay
so my goal is to hit 100 training points
and finish top 100
might be difficult but
we'll see
it's going to require bizarre
i'm going after a2 kind of
opening this
play knight b4
into d3
to be a little bit careful here
be really careful actually
just offer the queen trade
it looks really good
oh my bishop
[Music]
it takes it's made in two
oops
[Music]
let's go okay
turned into a difficult game
hey top 100 let's go
83 tournament points playing doctor
funny
i don't think i'll beserk this game
um
what to do
hitting the knight threatening f5
it's interesting
[Music]
okay so this funny line
and that a4 sack the knight takes an f5
or even f5 immediately
funny line against dr funny
it's all about initiative in this
position
i think i'm probably threatening to take
take away the king's shelter
getting made in one running the bishop
let's go
that's a funny game
[Music]
okay playing deeply epic
uh
no berserking
reverse grand prix
um
i'm thinking taking taking then uh f4 in
the end
some x-ray vision along the e file
now turning f3
and now it probably makes sense for
light to take
basically going all out here
very risky but it's interesting
there's this move
i mean let's go all out
a bad feeling about this
check nine of five
hey thank you crunchy something
i read
yeah i'm down a piece here
my all-out plan kind of backfired
hoping that opponent misses e2 but
i think it's time to resign
yeah let's resign
that was unfortunate still top hundred
thirteen points away from a hundred
tournament points
berserk
midnap is working back
um
under a bit of pressure here
wow
under a ton of pressure
i just want to trade stuff
it might be working out actually
the g file
equal material but i have more access to
the g file
oh no my oh actually my bishop
oh no
yeah
if this move maybe
it's not looking good though
[Music]
and now it's looking good
let's go
got the jobs on there
when they tried to dirty trick me at the
end too
hmm
i think this is okay
um
now that's probably slightly better here
winning connect four
that's a good move too
oh no my queen
enough seven
really
i didn't see any tactics there
oh no
[Music]
oh no
oh
okay
what's my score
90 points that's gonna be tough
it's still top hundred though acaro is
probably gonna win a bitcoin
wow
i didn't see magnus though
magnus
yeah let's play ultra aggressively takes
live queen before
interesting board geometry here
takes out of this move
and it's kind of a wacky position
did someone read
oh gotham raided what's up gotham
long time no see
gg by the way
appreciate the raid
if you're just joining i'm
[Music]
having a wacky game here
trying to not lose
it's a goal in life
okay getting some fun play
take this
probably doesn't work at all it looks
kind of funny though
oh my queen
at least i got a couple things for it
[Music]
oh no
don't hurt me
don't hurt me
not hurting me
no
oh that was a funny game though
thanks for the two dollars bonnie hit
man
okay this will probably be the final
game of the tournament so no berserking
staffing out of time
let's finish with something happy
hey opponent walked into one of the most
basic stafford traps
i'll take
the bishop d4
yeah white's under a lot of pressure
here queen before coming
you can probably take the pawn
i have queen here
so i want to swing back over
oh let's just keep the bishop
i have a feeling this game won't count
for the tournament
also i have a feeling we should witness
the final
standings who's winning
icaru paused for the boss he doesn't
even need to play the final
game or whatever
gigi hikaru
okay so this game will not count for the
tournament
but it will count for pride and glory
what to do
here's this move
i'm just keep pushing the pawn
[Music]
so if takes i take with f pawn open that
file
the bishop still defends the pawn
through x-ray vision
queen g5
i think i want to play f6
if takes i take take and then take
if takes takes takes i lose a pawn
okay so this is looking good
i mean this is a funny move
so if takes i have this move
okay
uh trying to finish happily
opponent's still fighting though
let me take the pawn
here's c5
nah
look at this
double my time
where'd all my time go
[Music]
oh if rook here i have this move
i want to play b5
okay
making some progress
i was white still alive here white's
like a cockroach
okay
oh
sorry to compare you to a cockroach
but uh anyway
the tournament is done
a lot of people quacking
okay hello to future youtube
if you've made it this far in the future
youtube video
leave a quack in the comments